bang bang what's going on guys hope you
guys are really excited about this
interview i really enjoyed it i think
you will as well but before we get into
that make sure that you
like this video so that more people on
youtube can find it make sure you're
subscribed to the channel
and don't forget that blockfi is the
sponsor today they've got three products
you can buy and sell crypto on their
crypto exchange you can deposit crypto
and earn up to 8.6
apy in an interest bearing account or
you can deposit crypto and take out a us
dollar loan against your crypto
collateral
you can use the description right here
or you can go to blockfi.com
to learn more all right let's get in
this episode i hope you guys enjoy this
one
all right guys bang bang i've got a very
special guest for you today i've got
jeremy here with me thank you so much
for doing this sir
thank you it's great to be back
absolutely
uh for those who didn't listen to the
first episode maybe just give us a quick
two minutes on your background
and kind of what you're doing today sure
so uh
we launched uh first of all i'm an
investment advisor i i
run uh investments for
um really kind of the five to 25 million
dollar net worth
uh family office who's not quite big
enough to create their own family office
but big enough to play in that space so
i'm you can think of me as an outsourced
family office solution i've got 19
families around the country that i do
that for
and uh you know in middle of 2017 that
led me down a rabbit trail to
investigate crypto
uh completely uh became enamored with it
launched a
hedge fund of funds pure crypto
in uh january 28th uh i'm sorry january
2018.
of course as we all know uh in hindsight
was impeccable
uh but yeah so i i've got a three-year
track record on that from now we're
launching pure crypto
2 or we just did january of of this year
and uh uh so we're here uh discussing
sort of what we've learned and and what
we're excited about and what may have
shifted and changed over the course of
the
uh three plus years so let's just start
with what's changed uh
which is a lot but go back from 2018 to
today
uh forget everything in between but just
like the sentiment in
uh january 2018 to uh sentiment in
january
of 2021 what are the biggest changes or
differences that you see
yeah clearly uh from a sentiment
standpoint
uh you know the the kind of maybe the
obvious biggest issue is just the
institutional adoption the uh
my my industry as a whole in
uh fourth quarter 2017 and certainly
even first quarter of 2018
kind of had that uh i told you so this
is a fraud this is horrible it'll never
work
kind of uh you know vibe and and and
all of those naysayers for the most part
uh have actually reversed quarters and
it's pretty interesting to see how that
has matriculated
that's one but i think the more
interesting one and the one i love to
sort i'm passionate about talking about
is when you look under the hood and you
you actually look at the inner workings
of how crypto has matured as an asset
class and by the way it's got a long way
to
go and and we're still we feel early in
the game
um you know in in the fourth quarter of
2017
uh venture capital investments in crypto
currency were really you know three week
to
three month kinds of investments right
these people
it was like the go-go days of the
internet you you get an interesting team
of individuals they
they you know they write a white paper
or create a marketing deck
and they go out and they raise capital
without having to create any technology
at all
and of course when the bubble popped
that went away immediately and you
couldn't go get money for free to come
build an idea before you'd done anything
of that with that idea today it's more
like traditional venture capital you got
to go
you got to go raise a seed round you got
to spend that money judiciously
you got to make some progress on your
technology you got to keep feeding it
you know a round b around c round and it
takes a while to get to your ico
initial coin offering probably three
years in most cases and
that one shift alone dramatically shifts
where value is created in the ecosystem
for cryptocurrencies and digital assets
as a whole
got it and so when you think through
this um you've got
a whole bunch of things that you could
offer to clients right you could do
fun to funds you could do indexing you
could do active management you could go
start your own uh company you could
start your own project whatever it is
walk through kind of your evaluation as
to where you play in the market and why
yeah so uh i mean i'll sort of do that
even historically i
you know when i when i sort of stumbled
you know in kind of middle of 2017 i
thought this is cool i'm gonna go raise
a hedge fund and start picking coins
then i realized well i've never
programmed a line of open source code in
my life i don't know how to do
that nor do i have an nsa level of
uh cryptography i don't understand that
right so
at that time all of the projects that
were interesting were really
kind of you needed those sciences you
needed people on your team that
really understood those in a very very
good way i didn't so
immediately i thought well if i'm going
to have value add in this space it's not
going to be on that end of the spectrum
so
we naturally shifted to funda funds in
my role as an advisor to wealthy clients
i'm
always looking at deals my you know my
ability to vet and source deals and ask
questions and try to find talent
that's kind of what i do for a living so
we just took those skills and tried to
apply them to this cryptocurrency world
and my most
passionate point in making that fun
structure
work was a belief that the asset class
was so
nascent that you did not want to
pigeonhole yourself with really
strong boxes you didn't want you know
like in in traditional finance you've
got morning star style
you know morning star box style on it
you know small cap growth large scout
value all that kind of stuff
this ecosystem doesn't have that yet and
you don't want that i think it's way too
early and still you want to go find the
smartest guys in the room and give them
the
widest mandate you possibly can because
the
the the landscape shifts so dramatically
so quickly
you can't box them in and and it'll be
years before we get to a place in this
industry where you want to actually
start boxing people in but that will
come eventually
yeah talk a little bit about active
management and kind of why that's so
important
well uh i'm maybe the first threat on
that is
go back to the idea of the venture
capital if you're
if you're in an index uh in the in the
early days
uh you know most of the value creation
in i'm going to say in the year 2017
might have been uh found in tickers that
were already trading publicly
not anymore right we have a position in
our portfolio through one of our
managers
called the graph the first trade post
ico in the graph
printed at 13 cents i believe it's
trading somewhere around 55 cents today
our cost basis is one tenth of a penny
and we were only able
to achieve that because we hired really
smart people that were super excited
about that project
before it went ico and so as an active
manager you've got to understand
how the ecosystem works wherever value
accrual
is happening and be able to move funds
uh
towards uh towards the part of the
market that is
accruing value in the most compelling
way
yeah and it's really fascinating to me i
guess that um
as you think through uh kind of that
active management
um not only is it going and finding some
of the stuff in the private market but
it's also then knowing when to
get out of the positions as well yeah
for sure
absolutely i you know the uh uh and
again
uh because i don't program open source
code
nor do i have uh any uh chop secret in
cryptography we we actually don't make
those calls i mean we are a
we are a traditional hedge fund of funds
we've got
five managers in our portfolio we're in
constant communication with them
they don't ask us our opinion on when to
sell
uh but our our bet is that we're with
the smartest herd and that there really
is a
small herd and i think that's actually
an important point
you know in 2017 i believe there were
less
and don't not 100 sure of the exact
number but i'm i'm
pretty sure that there were less than
five managers in
crypto that that ran liquid uh
cryptocurrency books greater than 50
million dollars in value
there was a really really there's
hundreds of funds but most of them had
really really small portfolios of
capital
under management uh and i'm not
including the venture capital guys i'm
just saying
actual liquid crypto guys right today i
bet you could count
less than a dozen hedge funds managing
liquid crypto books
of greater than 100 million dollars each
that's a really really small universe
i mean i can get on an airplane and go
see those guys
in three or four weeks all of them and
be and be
really close to to uh the biggest maybe
the biggest aren't always the smartest
but
their ability to attract capital
probably has some sense of
of um uh leaning or direction as to
whether they've got chops in the space
and so i just think it's such a small
space
there's so much misinformation there's
so much price discovery that isn't
really accurate in
in the spreads in the market and and
it's absolutely an active manager world
yeah talk a little bit about how your
clients are thinking about sizing this
in their kind of larger portfolios
and that'll kind of help people
understand like why that feeds into the
fact that some of these funds you know
only have
10 million and 50 million hundred
million dollars to them yeah for sure so
uh you know when we came out with the
fund in 18 we said you know
write a check that can go to zero like
literally i want you to write a check
if you you are not you have to lose
sleep you're not gonna uh it's not gonna
change your life it's not gonna really
impact your financial
at all and we think that's probably a
two to three percent
if we're wrong and crypto goes to zero
it
didn't change the portfolio shouldn't
change your life if we're right
and it goes 10x over the next five or 10
years or whatever 20x but
it can turn into real money that
conversation
we think today the floor is much higher
i mean we've survived
yet another 80 drawdown in the short
life of bitcoin's history
and you can't kill it and and the
institutional adoption
it's upon us and we think the technology
is here today so
we think double that allocation
reasonable for most
most investors although i have to say i
you know if you listen to this podcast
this is not investment advice i don't
know you
i don't know your portfolio situation
but just in terms of general broad
stroke understanding
space we think of it
so when you think through how uh
the space is evolving one of the things
that uh you've talked about in the past
is this like value accrual right so we
talked a little bit about
um kind of asymmetry and some of these
investments
if you're the average person sitting at
home
how do you think about this like can you
and should you go look for the active
managers is this something where people
should spend a bunch of time to get
educated and then go try to
uh trade or kind of pick you know stocks
would pick these like coins like how do
you just think about that from a wealth
management standpoint
yeah i you know i'm gonna obviously um
you teed me up really well thank you for
that i'm gonna talk my own book here
but i i i'm gonna talk my own book
because it's really what i believe it's
how i believe
this space should be impact but uh you
know the
uh there are in my opinion and i think
in most people
it's gonna be a little bit longer i hang
with as i explain this there's probably
seven
hedge funds managing liquid crypto books
that pretty much
most people think those are those are
the seven
best in this country i'm not talking
about europe or asia but i'm just saying
us domicile
crypto google asset
uh we have we have uh allocations to
five of those seven and the two that we
didn't allocate to it was by choice
two of those managers in our book are
closed cannot get
you cannot get new money into them the
third manager has a really high minimum
a million dollars they'll be closed
a fourth manager has high minimums
they'll they might be closed in like
three to six months somewhere in the
range so there's actually arguably in my
opinion
only one manager in our deck that has
some significant
room for for uh taking on new capital
and it's because that manager is really
looking at a value sector of the market
that's got way more runway
uh to it but all the traditional crypto
guys are getting full of capital there's
so much interest
and so uh from a capacity standpoint
your ability to get diversification and
get access to the smartest projects that
are out there
really really difficult even if you
spend the time
and go do the work and learn you know
learn how to
understand the code or the crypt of the
cryptography and
figure out how to get in the right doors
it's just a super high mountain to climb
as an individual
yeah and so when you start to think
through uh where's
bitcoin fit into all this right is it
still the king
and people should have exposure to it
are you of the belief that
people shouldn't have bitcoin how do you
just think about it given uh some of the
asymmetry
and value accrual you're talking about
in other parts of the market yeah i
would say
uh uh i don't think that way i think
absolutely people should have allocation
of bitcoin i think it's a very good core
holding
i think ethereum is the same way and i
think that uh
uh those are exposures that don't need
uh frankly a hedge fund with a carried
interest
i just don't think the market uh i think
the market has matured to a point where
we just don't need to pay somebody that
much
to to gain those exposures so i'm
absolutely
in favor of an allocation to bitcoin and
ethereum direct
um uh alongside an actively managed
portfolio
yeah and then when you think about some
of the interesting things that you've
seen
um are these uh decentralized protocols
are there specific like sub sectors in
crypto
that you're saying hey look this is
really where i want to spend a lot of
time
well for sure again with the caveat that
we don't make these calls we just listen
to all the smart guys in the room and we
get excited when they get excited but we
don't we're not actually directing them
you know so it's it's really uh they're
they're explaining those narratives to
us
but absolutely deep i is is uh d5 is the
first killer app if you will in my mind
like it is real world has real cash
flows it's the first place
in the ecosystem where you can take your
financial accounting 101 and
actually apply real business metrics to
a
to a token like like you know like
we we can talk about uniswap right
decentralized exchange
30 basis points of transactional volume
on a daily basis
uh a cruise to that token so hold on
before we get into the token component
of uniswap just explain unit swap at
kind of a high level first for those
that don't know it's decentralized
exchange it's nasdaq without the
middleman
okay and that basically means that
there's uh a pool of tokens if you own
some of those tokens then you
essentially have
uh ownership right a couple of that in
air quotes
of the cash flow for that decentralized
exchange that's correct
you have okay you have ownership is
right in air quotes
uh because that the the cash flow uh
uh a cruise to the token holders voting
rights
right so token holders could vote them
theoretically
uh to their neighbor uh but uh
but but there is and the token holders
get to vote where that
where that cash flow goes okay and so
walk through just like if you were to
look at it as like a company valuation
kind of that
uh that evaluation yeah so 30 bips
uh 0.3 of the transactional volume
on that exchange uh cruise uh as
cash flow to the token uh which uh on
seven
on an average of roughly 700 million
dollars of transactional volume a day
which by the way
has been growing like crazy i mean i
don't even know the number but it was a
fraction of that just
a year ago right so uh that's a 2.1
million dollar
daily cash flow haul which is about a
766 million dollar annual number
and i think if i i haven't looked at it
this morning i've been
on calls all morning but i'm pretty sure
the valuation of unit swap is somewhere
around four and a half billion which
puts this at
you know maybe about a 5x that cash flow
i hesita i hesitate to call it earnings
because that's like this capital thing
but you can kind of make that
and that's a value company like like
that that those
those are whether whether you called
exactly earnings or not
you know two years ago we were sitting
around a table saying well
you know how do you value a digital
asset it's not real i can't touch it and
it's just a series of numbers and codes
and it doesn't really spit off any
income and what is it and
we're past that there's a whole section
of crypto
that actually has real world cash flows
another example
in a different world would be spencer
dinwiddie's nba contract probably half
or more of your readership or listeners
know this
but there's an nba basketball player out
there who created his own token
to brilliantly so to pull forward his 15
million
or so nba contract in cash flows
you know he basically took his 15
million and sold it for 14 and a half or
whatever to create an implied yield for
the token holder
and basically asset back to that token
with real world rights to pro rata
ownership the cash flows of an mba
contract
um there's more and more of that
happening in crypto
or what i would more appropriately say
digital assets
and so when you think about like go back
to the unisop example is that just a
thing where
uh investors are undervaluing that like
it sounds like five times cash flow that
sounds
pretty uh low of multiple especially
given what's going on in the public
markets
uh is that the right way to think about
it is maybe that's actually the right
valuation like how do you wrap your head
around valuation versus
uh kind of the analysis of the actual
cash flow yeah that's that's so great uh
i
i i mean this is where it's i'm i'm
passionate about it but my opinion is
just that it's very open-handed opinion
uh but my opinion on that is it's just
that people don't know
i mean everybody you know 30 years ago
uh not very many people had money in the
stock market today it's ubiquitous like
a lot lower lower lower and lower levels
of net worth more and more
percentage population of the country
they they they have money in the markets
in one form or another through their
401ks or their iras or whatever
crypto is is nascent you know
just because it's true doesn't mean
people know it yet
that's the entire reason why there can
be that price dislocation because
because it's just a novelty people
people have people are still trying to
get their head
wrapped around how to own bitcoin much
less this funky token called uniswap
they've never heard
of absolutely and so when you think
through
kind of uh where the world's going do we
think that uh
all of the capital is going to flow out
of the stock market and into this kind
of digital world and there will be this
digital decentralized financial system
is there coexistence like just how does
this evolve over time
yeah i i love that like we uh you know
uh it kind of goes back to
you know uh we we've been saying
institutionals cap
capital is coming it's coming we've been
saying that for three years
and and it showed up but it showed up
first on the balance sheet of micro
strategies
treasury management nobody thought that
it's like we thought that one buffett
would come out and say oh this is good
stuff or or
you know ray daly uh sort of
institutional adoption and it came
from a really strange corner and i say
that because i think
i think whatever we think is going to
happen it's going to come out as from a
strange corner
uh so so i i don't mean to make that a
cop-out but it wouldn't surprise me
one bit if out of defending their own
territory i mean there's
lots of entrenched players that that
have a lot of motivation to try to keep
their turf
right so it wouldn't surprise me one bit
if ultimately the stock market
morphed i mean you know i think uh
i think we're seeing central banks do
that right if you can't beat them join
them figure out how to
don't kill it but figure out how to
co-opt it right power is important and
people love power and
people that have it aren't wanting to
let it go so i i don't exactly know how
that all collides but i think there's
there's uh there's a move towards this
technology no matter how it actually
gets adopted either by the winners or
the losers
yeah um talk a little bit about the
institutional adoption right so you talk
about microstrategy and we now see
all kinds of players coming out of the
woodwork right whether it's
um you know people who were in the
venture capital the kind of technology
forward space
you got people who um kind of are very
well-known publicly like
anthony scaramucci uh you've got big
institutions like fidelity
and others who who are starting to uh to
participate uh or have been for a couple
of years now
um just what do you think about the
institutional adoption and kind of the
impact of the market yeah my favorite
thing to talk about on this is actually
i feel like we're in the second
wave of institutional adoption now we're
entering it
the first one was you know those those
uh those those kind of uh trailblazers
the people that were willing to be the
first to take career risk
um and and and really sort of blaze a
trail for the others
right and there's been a number of those
those are well-documented players
the second wave is starting to figure
out
how to change the narrative like i think
one of the most perfect examples is
guggenheim is
fairly famous or maybe you could say
infamous the cio of
guggenheim for coming out and calling a
400 000 price target on bitcoin
right that was december 16th january
21st
he he comes back and says well it's it's
actually going to go to 20 000. before
it goes to 400 000
right i mean if that's not the most
blatant example of talking your book
right he
he kind of he kind of realized didn't
talk it up until he gets his entire
position in play right
you know blackrock filed very very
quietly
to have two of their funds be allowed to
own
bitcoin never sent a press release out
nothing was said anywhere
so you've got this stealth institutional
movement now
and that's that's the real meaningful
one that's the one where if they believe
it
uh strongly enough to not talk about it
but do it
uh it's a compelling uh investment
for sure uh talk a little bit about um
kind of the uh what's the best way to
talk about this
um as these institutions move into the
space
uh you will get the guggenheim's you
will get the black rocks you will get
kind of all of these players
uh but they're starting out buying
bitcoin they're not
going and looking at uniswap or kind of
the long tail of things and so uh
is it just there's an evolution and they
start out with bitcoin and then they go
look in ethereum and they kind of move
down the path or just
how exactly do you think that plays out
over time with the institutional
adoption across the asset class
i love this question i absolutely think
it's that for a couple of reasons i
think it's that because it's career risk
the institutional world
they've got safe jobs it's it's like
don't screw it up
right and so if if all of my neighbors
are buying bitcoin i can buy
them right but uh uh but what that does
is it creates
it creates a um kind of a bifurcated
market i mean the people that are buying
bitcoin and ethereum and maybe a couple
of other coins
are really a different set of investors
than everything else
and that allows this quote unquote
everything else
uh part of the market to be extremely
inefficient
and and uh if there's one thing uh
that's important
in having uh alpha and
active management it's finding
inefficient markets which there are very
few of today
absolutely uh what is the best thing
you've heard
uh in the last year so you talked a lot
of managers like what's the thing that
uh you're most excited about in uh the
entire industry
uh whether it's kind of a corner of defy
it's something that uh maybe you've
heard an investor say like just like
what's the thing that sticks out you're
like man this is
really really exciting and nobody knows
about it well
um so we've got a manager that and this
is hot off the press as of yesterday
uh you know we got a manager who's
setting up an spv to specifically target
um small cap d5
and and pretty much as as broadly as
possible across the d5 spectrum
and they they can't put it in their
larger fund because they're so thinly
traded their small cap and the
liquidity profile or constraints uh
doesn't really fit but it's it's the
most
interesting space in terms of value
accrual uh in terms of growth
of of transactional volume um that
that's going to change but for right now
we think that that is uh probably in my
mind
that's the thing that comes to top of
mind fastest is this
a small cap d5 which there's you know
there's
pretty much no way i'm gonna say that
you could probably replicate what
what we're investing in in that sleeve
uh unless you're one of these smart guys
in the room i mean
this is not a do-it-yourselfer homemade
portfolio
yeah i love it um what is the thing that
you think is most over hyped
in terms of people are talking about
what you think actually
uh is probably not gonna be sustainable
or valuable
oh that's a good question i'm not really
sure that there's
much that's overhyped um
you get a lot of disparate opinions on
you know what bitcoin's ultimate price
target
is um i if there is something like that
it's got to be in the bitcoin world
but i i don't know i don't think people
know where it's going to go
um i'm not sure i've got a good answer
for that question
that's fine you've you've got plenty of
good answers so uh so
not having one for one question is
perfectly fine
uh when you think through uh the
allocation um before we kind of get into
the rapid fire questions to wrap up
uh you started out with the uh the hedge
uh or the funda funds
um how do you think your clients are
thinking about it today is it
one allocation to one strategy is it
multi-strategy
um and will that also evolve over time
like will it
start to look like that multi-strategy
approach they uh
deploy in the nutritional world sure
yeah it will it will morph over time
right now we've got really wide mandates
and we know the dna
or we think we know the dna are the
managers you know one of them's kind of
got a trading mentality
you know coming out of uh uh goldman and
susquehanna you know
a couple of the others really are uh
just you know
coding tech geeks like deep science guys
trying to solve the big problems of the
world though that's a huge
allocation chunk um and then we got this
value guy
and and so broadly speaking we're
explaining that dna
uh really ten thousand foot view
um to our investor base and telling them
we
you know we don't wanna we don't want to
restrict them we don't put handcuffs on
them
um but as the as the asset uh class
matures
we will there there will be a time when
enough capital is in that to
differentiate and find alpha it's going
to get more crowded it's just not
crowded yet
yeah and it feels to me almost like uh
that's the natural market cycle right
it's just everyone
uh doesn't think something's a thing
there's a couple people who are early
adopters they get a bunch of alpha
uh over time their returns get
commoditized down and then when kind of
the uh you know mainstream or middle
market of the
uh investor base shows up uh you kind of
just get
a little bit higher than you got the
traditional world and then by the time
the last folks
get in uh you get kind of heavily
commoditized returns that look exactly
like the last market did
i i think that's the narrative for most
asset classes in history right you can
think about the quote-unquote hedge fund
the market neutral strategies or the
long short uh credit strategies or
any any niche in in the hedge fund world
that sort of was born
in the late 90s had some really
interesting return profiles with really
good alpha capture early on
but by the time you got to the um the
0.8 recession
it was ubiquitous there was so many
people and so much capital trying to
find that arbitrage it got arbitraged
away
and i and i i think this asset class
will do that too
i don't know where or how long but it
feels
a number of years away uh in my opinion
but but it'll it'll
it'll happen yeah it's pretty uh pretty
crazy
where do where can we send people to
find you on the internet or uh or
finding more about the uh the work that
you're doing
uh yeah pure dash crypto dot com
uh would be the uh website that's uh uh
discloses the uh the allowable the
regulatory allowable
information about the hedge fund um and
laureate
wealth dot com l-a-u-r-e-a-t-e dash
wealth dot com is my advisory practice
i don't think i ever asked you where did
laureate wealth and
pure crypt where the names come from ah
that's funny
laureate was just uh we were kicking
around trying we
we formed the company in 2009 and um
you know we just kept looking around
looking around and and it's a
laureate as a nobel laureate like it's a
wreath it's what the uh
it's what the greek uh olympians were
given when they won
and so it's a term of distinction it's a
place of honor
pure crypto is is just simply uh
you know we wanted something that
smacked of uh
hedge fund that had nothing but crypto
currency allocations in it so it's kind
of simple but
that's a pretty self-explanatory name
there
not very creative but it's what we got
all right so i'm gonna ask you uh two
questions i've already asked you my
normal questions
uh but i'm gonna ask you two new
questions uh before we go to wrap up and
you get to ask me one question
uh the first is a uh is a very fun one
uh which is what is the craziest thing
one of your clients has said to you
about bitcoin or crypto
in the last three years oh
the craziest thing
oh i it's probably fairly uh boring i i
probably have had
half of my clients at least uh
become morally offended by my
identification
with uh you know silk road transit
action
basically that that's a pretty strong
model
it's a false narrative uh i mean of
course
you know lots of lots of interesting
tech starts in nefarious
places i mean that's kind of a thing uh
but that doesn't mean that uh
doesn't mean they carry that dna forward
absolutely i couldn't agree more
uh second question is more personal uh
this comes from our friends at eight
sleep they've got this thermoregulated
uh bed that basically makes it super
cold
i use it every night it's amazing
absolutely love it uh
are you a five or six hour sleeper are
you a nine or ten hour sleeper
what's kind of a sleep routine and how
much sleep do you get well i'm
embarrassed to say
uh i will say i try to hide this from my
clients so maybe they won't watch
or listen but i am a dude i'm an old man
like i'll be 50 in june if i don't get
eight and a half hours of sleep i am
just no good to
anybody my wife my kids my business i'm
just like i gotta have i gotta go
i gotta get my sleep and i gotta work
out and i gotta eat right
yeah that that's a that's a good thing i
think it used to be that people were
like you know i'll sleep when i'm dead
right but now i think the tides turn to
people realizing hey sleep's pretty damn
important
we probably should make sure that we're
doing that yeah i am yeah i'm definitely
an eight and a half
nine if i can get it guys i love it
what uh what one question you have for
me to finish up
uh i'm just be curious uh
other than crypto what's the most
interesting
investment that you're super excited
about right now
early stage venture capital um i'm just
a big believer that uh
innovation drives returns and uh early
stage venture capital is by far
um kind of the best place to go find
that you're looking for the asymmetry
uh in some ways you know some of the
markets you're talking about with
venture
or frankly uh you know uh or in crypto
or basically venture type investments
right kind of zeros or heroes
um it's just that they're not equity
they're this token based thing
and so i think that um that's probably
it within that um
i don't know if i could pick like an
individual sector that i'm like oh this
is you know going to be amazing
um over everything else because i just
think that across the board
uh early stage venture is just driven on
innovation and that's where you're going
to get kind of outsized returns and so
that's what i'd pick
yeah no good word and and really um
that's
that's the way we coach our uh investor
base to think about
crypto even though it's liquid it's
venture it's venture capital even post
ico it's
a there's nothing in there's nothing in
the digital asset
space that's not venture capital today
i uh i couldn't agree with you more
there my friend so listen thank you so
much for doing this again
uh we will have to uh continue to do it
as as we check
in on basically what the sentiment among
your wealthy clients are but also kind
of how the
the fund's doing and what you're seeing
from all the different managers
very cool thanks for having me i really
enjoyed it